القضيه الاساسيه التي يتحدثون عنها ائمه
المساجد في خطبه العيد يتحدثون عن الوضع
الامني ويطالبون القاده العسكريين الى وقف
لاطلاق النار والى
الشعور المواطن في الخرطوم بالعيد هذه
الاوضاع ما تزال مستمره
الهدنه التي
ابرمته
خلال سبعه ايام الماضيه اسبوع الماضي كانت
هشه لم تستقر ولم تصمت طويلا وتعرضت
الانتهاكات وتبادل الطرفان الجيش السوداني
وكذلك قوات الدعم السريع
مسؤوليه هذه الانتهاكات وتحديد هذه
المشاكل لكن مازلنا نحن هنا في الجنوب
الخرطوم
الناس
يعتقدون ان ان هذه الازمه مهما استمرت
لابد لها ان تنفرجوا ان تزول لكن
الفواتير التي دفعت النظير هذا الاقتتال
وهذه الازمه الكثيره هناك عدد كبير جدا من
المستشفيات خرجت خارج الخدمه كذلك
توفر المواد الغذائيه انقطاع مياه الشرب
في عدد من المناطق تعطل بعض الخدمات
الاخرى كذلك الخدمه المصرفيه المتعلقه
بالبنوك هناك جماعه تجعل من هذه المدينه
الخرطوم مدينه غير صالحه للعيش بصوره
الجيده